hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt heute gibt es bei mir wieder
ein von land video und in diesem video
zeige ich euch wie ich eine kleine 20
zentimeter torte hersteller wie ich den
boden backe wie sie fühle bestreichen
und damit von und auf einem über ziel
und schließlich dann auch wie ich sie
dekorieren bei von torten ist es ganz
wichtig dass ihr sorgfältig arbeitet das
heißt auch der kuchen den evagt da muss
schon eben sein und gleichmäßig habt ihr
später nämlich viel weniger arbeit
den kuchen dann glas zu streichen und
euer von tante ihr später dann auch die
torte auflegt kann nur gut sein wenn der
kuchen und runter schönen glatt
gestrichen ist so eine torte brauche
etwas vorbereitung und ich zeige euch
jetzt einfach mal wie ich vorher
befürchtet mache zum beispiel die torten
form auslege und wie ich das dann
hinbekommen dass der kuchen schön
gleichmäßig backt bevor es jetzt an den
teig geht zeige ich euch wie man die
backform richtig auslegt als ihr müsst
es nicht machen aber dadurch backteig
gleichmäßiger und ihr habt später einen
ebenmäßigen kuchen
ich bin erzählt er dann in bagdad ihr
könnt aber auch eine ganz normale
springform nehmen
dann schneidet ihr euch streifen aus der
verknüpfung diesen etwa zwölf zentimeter
breit
die kriegt ihr jetzt da unten ab so etwa
12 cm schlägst du übereinander damit ich
nur einmal die arbeit habe und dann
schneidet ihr bis zum krieg im abstand
von ungefähr zwei zentimetern so
streifen ein
dann sieht es häufig so aus der
kooperation danach nehmt ihr euch den
backend und jetzt geht's einfach wenig
den vorher an feuchte und dann legt ihr
dauert diese streifen rain den anfang
könnt ihr mit so einer art klammer
fixieren und schön an wollten
über fixiert und auf den boden dafür
legt ihr einen kreis den ev
herausgeschnitten habt den habe ich mit
hilfe des parkraums ausgeschnitten
welch ein bisschen kleiner als recht
reinigung und dann habt ihr so ne super
ausgelegte backform jetzt zeige ich euch
noch wir den kuchen isoliert backen kann
das heißt es der kundin streifen an den
rand des kuchens damit der gleichmäßig
backt und dazu nehme ich euch eine
alufolie und schneidet die so lang wie
der umfang des toppen handels oder der
springform und dann kommt da lag zehn
oder klopapier geht auch ich mache jetzt
mal zwei lagen und die macht ihr jetzt
kurz nas und drückt sie schön aus
aufpassen dass damit reist also war ich
ein bisschen stabiler habe ich aber
keiner da
und dann wird es einfach vor
das ende verurteilt ihn jedoch kurz und
auf der anderen seite genauso und dann
habt ihr so einen streifen alufolie
nehmt euch dann eure backwaren und die
querstreifen außenrum die zu stellen ein
bisschen zu lang mir ein bedürfnis ist
nicht doppel legen sonst ist das
doppelte solid und wachsen gleichmäßig
das heißt ich schneit es hier weg und
stand glaube ich hier gerade einmal um
das business rausguckt und es wird dann
auch mit seinen körper fixiert und dann
könnt ihr auch schon den teig herstellen
und wie das geht zeigen euch jetzt ich
hab den bananen rück kuchen in einer 20
cm springform oder in meinen bart rahmen
gebacken und falls ihr die mengen
variieren wurde müsst ihr einfach das
rezeptbuch oder runter rechnen und beim
rührteig ist jetzt wieder wichtig dass
alle zutaten die gleiche temperatur
haben
so bekommt ihr nämlich einen schritten
schönen glatten rührteig für meine 20 cm
springform benutze ich jetzt 125 gramm
butter 125 gramm zucker 2 eier größe m
150 gramm mehl eine halbe packung
backpulver einen halben teelöffel natron
wenig ein natron habt könnt ihr noch
einen halben teelöffel backpulver meter
zu geben
25 gramm kaka und halben bis dreiviertel
teelöffel zimt und eine kleine brise
gemahlene nelken und stand braucht ihr
noch zwei bananen zuerst kommt jetzt die
butter in die rührschüssel da kommt
jetzt der zucker mit rein und dann wird
es auf höchster stufe cremig gerührt
ihr müsst auch bei so küchenmaschinen
immer mal wieder
zwischendrin gucken auf alles berührt
wird
dann kommen da jetzt die eier noch mit
rein und es wird dann noch mal schön
verrührt
dann vermischt de kurs die trockenen
zutaten miteinander als auch backpulver
und natron zu mehr noch zimt und nelke
mit dazu das gibt dir dann hier ein noch
der ko mit rein und in der zwischenzeit
habe ich schon mal die bananen mittag
gab's da drückt wieder ruhig noch so
wissel stück ich sein
ich bekomme dort auch mit reifen und
dieser geruch des cash einfach unfassbar
also es ist schon richtig leckere
bananen rührkuchen
das wird einmal ganz kurz berührt
du musst immer aufpassen sobald mail im
teig mit drin ist dürfte nicht mehr
lange röhren sonst weder teig nicht
schön locker weil sich da irgendwie
dieses dieser kleber im mehl löst also
sobald medien zu kommt nur noch solange
verrühren bis das mehl komplett
eingerührt und ihr solltet auch eure
früher stäbchen niemals am rand
abklopfen sollte diese ganze luft wieder
raus die hier eingeschlagen haben
das wird es einmal und verrührt wenn
euch der teig zu fest steht ihr einfach
entweder noch ein bisserl banane mit
rein oder im schuss mädels aber so ist
ja eigentlich prima hier noch kurz
gucken dass man zur mail klümpchen drin
dann kommt der teig in die vorbereitete
springform wenn ihr nur ein ganz
normaler rührteig macher volt kann es
auch in kapselform backen oder eben den
normalen springform da müsst ihr das
auch nicht mit backpapier auskleiden
sondern reich fragt papier am boden den
rand braucht ihr nicht einfetten und
dann alles noch schön verstreichen
die menge passt auch gut in 18
zentimeter springform der kuchen wir
dann bei 160 grad ca 50 minuten gebacken
ich mache auf jeden fall die stäbchen
probe und sagt später nochmal genau wie
lange jetzt wirklich gebacken hat falls
ihr den kuchen mit der isolations
methode parkt müsst ihr bedenken dass er
viel länger braucht zum backen das heißt
plant euch da schon rechtzeitig viel
zeit ein
bei mir hat der kuchen es nämlich etwa
70 minuten gebacken und nun ganz sicher
zu gehen macht ihr einfach die stäbchen
probe dann seid ihr immer auf der
sicheren seite und ich habe der hesse
ungefähr eine halbe stunde abkühlen
lassen
man könnte die sparte für ein verdienst
dann kommt der kuchen auf einen kuchen
rost und kann vollständig auskühlen
ich lasse jetzt mal das backpapier dann
drunter sonst habe ich diese stäbchen
später in dem kuchen drin und so las ich
denn jetzt einmal komplett auskühlen den
kuchen bevor ich dann nach dem auskühlen
mit etwas marmelade und mit etwas tat
peter karrasch das rezept für die zar
peter gersch findet ihr bereits auf
meinem blog im cake pops artikeln
aber ich schreibe auch zu diesem video
einen blogbeitrag und da findet ihr dann
auch noch mal das genaue rezept zur
herstellung der ganache folgt dann auch
bald ein video das welt irgendwann in
den nächsten wochen man hochladen
dann habt ihr das nämlich auch gleich
und wie gesagt die garage hatte ich
schon hergestellt und zeige ich es
einfach wie ich sie verarbeiten und dass
ihr müsst ihr wegschmeißen ihr könnt es
dann aufmachen und immer wieder nass
machen was du noch drei vier mal wird
das austauschen ohne neuen rolle rein
machen oder eben neue neues
toilettenpapier der rührkuchen schütz
komplett ausgekühlt ich lasse jetzt so
also dass sich die unterseite ich habe
der freund gestürzt so habe ich nämlich
eine schöne glatte oberfläche jetzt
nehme ich mir eine kleine trocken platte
das ist so eine kleine platte
die habe ich in der größe der torte
zurechtgeschnitten und da gebe ich jetzt
ein ganz kleines bisschen von ganache
drauf und stark kommt dann der boden
drauf und verrutscht und auch nicht mehr
es wird der kuchen noch zurecht
geschnitten dazu stelle ich den kuchen
auch so einen drehteller ich möchte
jetzt einmal nur halbieren
dann setze ich hiermit ich an und hier
oben ganz leichter druck nur als ich heb
nur die toiletten kuchen fest und dann
sehe ich das messer ganz sanft dadurch
und schon habt ihr zwei bilden
auf den unteren boden gebe ich jetzt ein
bisschen marmelade
das ist quitten konfitüre
das müsst ihr nicht machen könnt ihr
aber ich finde dadurch schmeckt
etwas wuchtiger und ihr könnt auch jede
beliebige marmeladen aprikose passt
immer ganz gut gebe es hier noch ein
bisschen nach oben drauf
und dann setze ich den zweiten boden
wieder drauf und strücken schön flach
und den rand ziehe ich dann mit so einer
zeitkarte ab vorsichtig da brüstet
nämlich ziemlich ich habe jetzt hier
etwas wunderbares rausgenommen
die habe ich jetzt zwar schon seit 23
stunden im zimmer stehen aber die ich
immer noch steinhart deswegen gebe ich
dir jetzt ganz kurz in die mikrowelle
und zeigt euch dann welche konsistenz
sie haben muss und so sollte dann die
konstanz von ghanas haben wenn ihr dort
damit einstreichen wollen und so könnte
sie dann eben ganz gut verwenden und
verstreichen
es hat so eine art konsistenz von
nutella ungefähr
und ich hab das jetzt in der mikrowelle
bei höchster stufe immer so 10 bis 20
sekunden geschmolzen dann ungerührt
wieder geschmolzen
hier noch kurzen tief für euch wenn ihr
euch immer wieder ganache aufwärmt und
das dann mit dem schneebesen verrühren
habt ihr gleich eine glatte masse und
derart lange rummachen wenn ihr das dann
habt kommt da eine kleine menge ganache
obendrauf
mit dieser ersten schicht wollte er erst
mal die krümel binden
einfach schön von der mitte nach außen
streichen
dann bis an den rand
auch da unten da wo das brett ist und
dann auch mal die karte benutzen die es
ist ganz gut wenn wir hier so im rechten
winkel habt dann einfach die karte
ansetzen und ich sehe auch dass das
später noch eine lücke ist und ich
möchte dass der kuchen im rechten winkel
hat und dafür sich später auch gerne
schreiben
ein bisschen abgezogen und stellt ihn
jetzt für etwa fünf bis zehn minuten in
den kühlschrank
den kuchen den müsst ihr in mehreren
schritten mit glatt streichen
die erste schicht sorgt dafür dass ihr
die grübel bindet und dass da keine
krönchen mehr abfall
danach stellte den kuchen wieder in den
kühlschrank holt ihn wieder heraus dann
kommt eine zweite und eventuell dritte
schicht traum habt ihr einfach so lange
bis ein kuchen so schön glatt ist wie
ihr ihn haben wollte und danach lasst
den eine nach dem kühlschrank holen und
danach kann dann mit von hand gezogen
werden
doch schon morgen mehr
red
aber so
ar jri
lol
hannover durch stern ist ein google habe
ich auch schon vorbereitet zeige ich
euch einmal ganz schnell wie ich den
kuchen damit überziehe und nachdem
übersehen muster kuchen wieder eine
nacht in den kühlschrank und in der zeit
bereit ich kann schon mal die deko vor
wie zeigt man
so
marcel koller ist also wir uns sieht es
dort und anschließend zum media
lustig wie
can speak
jetzt ist genommen
ich habe den kuchen in den kühlschrank
gestellt
derzeit mache ich schon mal die
dekoration aus blüten passte ich habe
mich jetzt bewusst nur für blüten passte
entschieden damit die deko schnell
trocknet und ich dann gleich benutzen
kann
die blüten passte rolle ich jetzt
einfach dünn aus schneidet sie dann in
die beliebte form und pins lässt sich
später mit lebensmittelfarbe und die
lebensmittelfarbe habe ich dieses mal
mit etwas alkohol angemischt und so mit
einem pinsel dann einfach auf die
trockene blüten passt immer halt der
vorteil von alkohol ich einfach dass er
schnell verdunstet und die farbe dann
schnell trocknet ob es mit wasser geht
weiß ich nicht das müsst ihr
ausprobieren aber wie gesagt das ist ja
elo für die dekoration und meistens für
die deko ich mitgegessen also ja müsst
ihr selber dann entscheiden ob es machen
wollt oder nicht
da
eine technische habe der macd wieder
krebs
prince michael
liebe es
eine
juni
die kirche wird
der aufschrei
ich werde meine geile
pikachu
bei youtube
webber 3
habil
b
rang vor
hier
von
b
fahrt
das geht nicht
sein
top ist nicht tot
bis 4
kevin frank
h
v
denkbar
erwähnt
sobald die oberfläche der torte und
dekoration getrachtet ist könnt ihr die
deko auf die torte aufsetzen und mit
etwas kleber draufkleben die torte ist
und etwa vier bis sechs tage haltbar
die deko würde ich vorher zum
anschneiden wegnehmen die ich nämlich
ziemlich hart weil sie nur aus blüten
passte besteht außerdem schmeckt
eigentlich nur nach zucker und falls ihr
noch weitere fragen habt zu foltern und
töten passte dann schreibt mir gerne
kommentare unter dieses video oder bei
facebook auf meine pinnwand
falls ihr noch video wünsche habt so
fondant irgendwie genauere
beschreibungen zum bestreichen oder zu
glatt streichen der torte
dann können die mit es auch gern
schreiben ich versuche dann das beste
draus zu machen und euch die fragen zu
beantworten
jetzt wünsche ich euch viel spaß beim
nachmachen ich hoffe das video hat euch
ganz gut gefallen und bis zum nächsten
mal
bier
in fahrt